welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
titled discovery and development of a
novel first in class resuscitative agent
as my pleasure to introduce to you
professor in neo galati professor
galerias chairman and the chief
executive officer of farmers
incorporated and is an adjunct professor
at the colleges of pharmacy and graduate
studies Midwestern university the
department of bioengineering at
University of Illinois at Chicago
Illinois for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
located at the top of your screen
my name is Xavier guitars and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and this
presentation is educational and the
soccers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming professor and Neil
Khiladi I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello everyone this is Ann
in Gulati and actually I'll be talking
about the discovery and development of a
novel first and pass this acetate away
then and I'll give you a brief how we
discovered it how we are developing it
and how we are planning to take it all
the way to the market so basically this
product is for massive blood loss and
lost blood loss
mainly takes place from as a result of
trauma postpartum hemorrhage GI bleeding
complicated surgeries drugs like aspirin
and others they can cause massive top
and there is the whenever there is blood
loss the first thing medical attention
is needed is to control the blood loss
of blood and then old ventilation at
cardiovascular function and many times
the these are intensive efforts and
there is a significant unmet medical
need although there is very extensive
research which has been carried out but
mortality still remains very high and
there is almost like 20% or 25%
mortality and some of the developing
countries close to 3035 percent
mortality in such people so there are
two types of laws or hemorrhagic
talk with a controlled Ambridge shot
where the source of needing is occluded
these are easy to end but most of the
time what we come across is uncontrolled
and the tic-tock feeding is temporarily
stopped and most the time it is because
of hypertension that blood pressure goes
down so the pressure in the heart races
and the clot forms and tries to stop but
sometimes the problem is when beery
perfused the clot dislodges and once
again the bleeding occurs so what we try
to do is we try to restore the pulse try
to respond sense helium and we the
phenomena of hypotensive resuscitation
that is obtaining blood pressure of
about 80 millimeter mercury so because
of this unmet medical medical need
nothing much has been discovered or
passed before he ears ought to use it
and there is the so Preston has been
used and recently angiotensin ii has
been approved by fda but really nothing
major has happened
accepting use or be suppressed
the problem in vasopressors is that they
constrict the artery
if the arteries are constricted the
blood flow will be impaired although the
blood pressure is going up the blood
flow is likely to be impaired so this
compound center pen this in our animal
models of RAD schemata love fix pressure
blood loss the rabbit model of
uncontrolled bleeding with trauma a pig
model of massive blood loss in most of
these different models we found that
it's used mortality it decreased blood
lactate levels and increased our teal
pressure pulse pressure and most
importantly cardiac output please and we
also went ahead because this was a new
molecule and never being any scientific
or international non proprietary name
was not there so we approached whu-oh
and got the name of proved and happened
with an e that has been approved no that
is the official name for the compound so
this tracing is the first one in which
we first experiment which we did in
which we found that because model will
use the blood pressure on the top two
panels at the bottom in the heart rate
and you can see that the blood pressure
drops down to 35 millimeter mercury and
we keep it but 30 minutes we keep it at
35 for 30 minutes and then we
resuscitate and at 30 minutes when we
resuscitate with hands up and we can see
that the blood vector is going up but
surprisingly the heart rate is going
down and most of the visible crystals
which are used today the heart rate
booked up and so this was a surprising
and novel finding which VM which we took
into account and and expanded our
studies to measure the left ventricular
pressure left ventricular volume in
which you can see the loops are
generated and the loops the diameter or
the width
tells us the SPRO column that is of
important thing which we could note and
the height tells us the pressure and one
in the sham and these pressure volume
loop
can see that there is not much of change
but when the blood loss occurs we can
see that pressure has dropped and the
width also has dropped so the stroke
volume has reduced significantly when we
resuscitate with 3% saline in the middle
panel we see there is some resuscitate
or some improvement is to call you my
treasure but it is transient and by 240
minutes none other animal survived and
all of the time whereas in sensor pen
you can see that the pulse pressure the
are left ventricular pressure and the
stroke volume are significantly improved
and 240 minutes also that is good supper
so this is an example of a pig study
which was done in greece by theodore
samples bro and so where the severely
Hambridge pigs almost 50% of blood was
lost and then they were resuscitated
with either saline or the center pin
plus baleen and we can see to bring the
blood pressure back to baseline and we
can see that when we needed close to 2.2
liters of fluid to bring the blood back
to baseline but and when we added since
our friend the blood pressure was only I
mean the blood volume it was needed or
the volume of fluid today was only 3 so
after two hours of experiment there were
only two out of ten named ml survived in
the control group and all 10 out of 10
survived in 24 hours later zero none
survived in the control group and nine
out of ten survived so this was a good
indicator of survived now this is a very
this is from the same swine study in
which 50 percent blood was lost and we
can steal on the top panel is the
cardiac output and bottom is systemic
vascular resistance the red one is the
control and blackest and happen you can
see a significant increase in cardiac
output which has taken place didn't
happen what happens to vascular
resistance it goes down most of the ways
of crystals which are used today they
increase vascular resistance and this
one uniquely decreased where that
so that is something very very important
and then further studies were carried
out in another group of big model by
Teodor and we found that when try ratio
or the lung capillary permeability was
significantly improved aerobics
ingesting say horowitz index
significantly improved so that the lung
functions of pulmonary edema is less
like before when mortality also was
significantly improved the unique
approach of this is it has the potential
to be a first-class therapy the reason
is there is no compound which can
increase which is the increasing cardiac
output and decreasing vascular
resistance in hypovolemic shock this is
a unique thing with it so a unique way
of treating patients with massive
Mackerras olfaction how does it act
there are lot of receptors present at
par to be receptors are on the venous
side and they increase means are
political in Fisher and that leads to an
increase in capital simultaneously in
central our system there are alpha 2 a
which are compatible detect and they
will decrease vascular resistance and
decrease blood pressure net effect of
these two is an increase in blood
pressure in hypovolemic shock
that means the venous part is P
dominating so what is happening is
sensical stimulates alpha to be venous
receptors which increase venous return
to the heart increase cardiac output
heart pumps more blood per beat and
improves tissue perfusion while
simultaneously attacks on alpha 2 a2
decreased empathic drive blood vessels
are dilated on the arterial side is
dilated and the blood flows easily
through the fish or to through the
vessels so 70 percent of our blood is
pooled on the venous side which is
effectively not circulating or supplying
oxygen and nutrition 30 percent arterial
side is the one which is supplying then
terpenes because of its meanness alpha
to be receptors
moves that blood towards the arterial
silence or things like so
veins are very compliant they can
accommodate a large amount of blood and
that by almost 80 70 % of blood is food
on the penis plate so this was the basic
mechanism which I just didn't you
sedated but now I will give you some of
the clinical data we embarked on
clinical phase one study which was done
in the center and what we did was we did
single ascending those particular thing
those two single ascending those was
four groups and multiple ascending those
was in two groups
so one selected those for hypovolemic
shock is 0.01 the wind 5 times higher
there was no adverse effect 10 times
however there was no 15 fold higher
that's the time and we saw the adverse
affect multiple attending those there
was no adverse event report so in other
words the safety is so high that we can
go even tenfold higher and no
significant adverse effects were will
observe so once again in ICU setting
most of the drugs which we use
particularly with subtitles and others
which we use we I mean you increase the
dose and chances of adverse effect that
the safety is very very big and adverse
effects are also very they are expected
for example hypotension was observed
when 15 fold higher dose was used and
this was affected because of alpha 2 a
activity in the CNS which is causing a
foreign blood pressure so that dominated
and pollen will return and this lasted
for 1 hour 5 minutes in this patient and
or subject and resolved by itself no
medical intervention was needed for any
of that one other minor adverse effects
like drowsiness and all that timeout are
expected because
clonidine like sham so no major adverse
cause served in so we have established
the safety and maximum tolerated those
was found to be 0.1 milligram per
kilogram well tolerated both single and
thing
sending those and multiple attending
propose doses 0.01 milligram per
kilogram it is tenfold or ten times
lower than the maximum politic it has
hot the short half-life with large
volume of display so basically once the
phase one was established that it is
safe and the we embarked on human phase
2 studies and so it was a prospective
multicentric randomized blinded
parallels felon controlled phase two for
excessive blood loss all the subjects
received standard treatment per star so
whichever is the standard treatment
which was to be there as soon as the
patient arrived and when the systolic
blood pressure became less than ninety
protocol standard would be sufficient
picked it and that's how the patient
world
@ej so one arm was controlled where
standard treatment was given and the
second arm was and that pen of teams in
2010 where they receive the standard
treatment in addition they got sense of
these are some of the center's seven
centers in India where the trial was
done to 137 patients were Spain and
fifty-one enrolled so out of fifty
enrolled 22 in the control completed the
study and 23 in sent up and completed so
we will present the data on those
demographics you can see that the
control as well as interpret the gender
the very similar ages similar between
the two gross body weight is also
similar height BMI and body surface area
both are similar so basically telling us
that we are comparing apple to Apple and
these groups are comparable to each
other further the number of doses per to
be 48 hours also but similar between the
two groups and they statistically they
were not different now the important
thing is whether the blood loss Hitler
or not for haematocrit level the
we can see that hematocrit levels also
in both probes are very very similar to
the math the blood loss also in both the
groups are similar to each other so once
again emphasizing once again that these
are comparable groups and they are
similar to injury scoring value this is
also an important marker so some
patients it could have been argued that
one gun the one group will maybe have
more injury and be having that fee but
here we can see that injury scoring
value is similar to the p value it's
points:5 sick so that means they are not
picking fluids infused over the first 48
uppers are also similar they are not
different and blood vols blood products
like platelets or RBC's or blood when
they were transfused they were also
similar between the two groups so both
groups received similar amount of fluid
in first 48 hours and similar blood
products in the first number of patients
on based off testers or the patients
needing risk of testers it was about 41%
in standard treatment and 26% in so
there is a trend that there is a
decrease in number of patients requiring
we hope that when we use that topic now
this was not statistically significant
but there is a clear trend and the
amount of waste of crystals which are to
be infused which were infused in first
48 hours is 9 I compared to 3 about so
from 9 it dropped to 3 but standard
errors are quite high so there is a
trend there's less number of patients
are requiring we suppresses the amount
of it suppresses needed in this group is
less but statistically it has not come
out be significant so the percentage
time in hospital how much of time was
spent in ICU also is similar there is a
trend that there is some degrees in ICU
stay but predominantly it is
statistically not sick so time on
ventilator from
two days down to one day but errors are
high so there is a trend that there is
decrease in time spent on it
artistically did not come theorem
creatinine values the one we can see
that both control and and sentiment
group they are showing improvement in
p.m. period the p-value is 0.065 control
and 0.009 and happen to this level of
significance but this tells us all the
story is telling us that the control or
standard treatment also is working and
that is a very very important part in a
clinical trial that the standard
treatment should be working and here
patients are recovering due to standard
treatment also glamour of filtration
rate very similar to serum creatinine so
0.003 in control and 0.000 in center pen
now comes the important killing clinical
biomarkers with a blood pressure based a
fitted blood lactic suitable and I will
go through these clinical biomarkers we
can see that the red is the standard
treatment and green is standard
treatment look happen so we can see that
the blood pressure is very clearly
better in sensor pengrove compared to
standard and when we do individual
patient analysis here in this so we can
see that the systolic blood pressure
when we compare 0 to 12 hours or 0 to 24
0 to 48 hours they reach barely
significance and in some cases over 12
hours they did not even teach level off
whereas then sent up and drove highly
significant less than 0.0001 in all
cases whether it is 0 to 12 0 to 24
hours equal 48 hour
diastolic pressure it is the separation
is a little bit more clearer and when we
do individual patient analysis then to
analyze the variance find that the
p-value
you did not reach the level of
significance with the control group but
in-center can grow it is 0.0001 and less
so highly significant improvement in -
good so based of a said which is which
has improved in both the cases but in
center can broke it came based acted so
individual patient analysis there is
improvement in both but the level of
improvement for the p value changes
learnt lactate level which is one of the
most important indicator of mortality
significantly decreased in control from
4 to 3 and from 4 to 1.4 in cent of them
so highly significant decrease in sense
that when growth but in control there
was a minimal so degree so blood lactate
level when we compare individual patient
analysis it is showing that there are
from 0 to 3 days the p-value is
0.29 it did not reach the level of
significance better than 10,000 growth
atleast highly significant decrease in
blood lactate so here there are two
patients which I bound to empathize
patient 10 in control and patient 12 in
the treated group so this patient these
two patient zero five zero zero five and
zero zero six these are the two subject
so zero zero five is the control saline
and and zero zero thickness the center
pen you can see that both are females
both had pregnancy which went wrong and
one is 24 years age and there is 31
years of age one had 0:05 which is the
Saline group and paste that hemoglobin
level of P for the patient in center can
grow panda he booked a three-point stick
and the patient in Saline group died and
the patient
second group survived and lactate level
in in the country Selene group patient
that was zero zero five was eleven point
one eight and it went to fifteen point
three and the patient died on then
within the first day while the patient
Hans Center friend group at lactate
level of seventeen point four one and on
third day the patient had lactate level
of two point and this patient so there
were total mortality there were two
deaths in the control group and zero non
death in the tenth effect so adverse
events there were three adverse events
reported in control and two incense up
and rope but these events were not
related to the drug because the acute
kidney injury one of the adverse he went
huge kidney injury was in a patient with
a stab wound where this where the knife
went all the way to the kidney and
damaged the kidney also so the kidney
injury was because of the move because
of the stab and not because of the truck
so how it is given Vedas all the
contents in a while which is 10 ml of
number V reconstitute 0.1 milligram of
serpent which becomes 0.1 milligram per
ml and then supposing if the body weight
is 70 kilogram he takes happen ml of
this person to reconstitute in 100 ml of
normal saline in the bag and infuse over
Bonaparte so it's not it is a very
simple procedure the while we take put
10 ml of saline it solve it in five to
10 second it dissolves and then we take
according to body weight whatever amount
such pentane hundred mailbag use over so
how does it act as a physiology so can
happen as we know that it increases
venous pressure when
infuse and that increases venous return
when people are filling Bo's Armand that
sub-prime starlings law more ventricular
filling mole will be pumped out so
particular contraction increased stroke
volume increases and that leads to
increasing fatty but simultaneously
center pin also I told you in the first
flight that he is with heart bed if the
heart rate decreases then the diastolic
time decreases and diastolic time
decrease that will allow more of filling
time or die static time will increase
and more of filling time will increase
for more time now for the blood to fill
into the left ventricle that increases
left ventricular filling pitching
pleases ventricular stretch and
kata-kata now when we are infusing
fluids and blood and that they are also
increasing the blood volume
so all that combination toads and blood
volume they are towards are infused they
are singing things the blood volume
filling time increasing that is impeding
the event
venous pressure is increasing the
appendicular filling so all that to any
product purple and that leads to and
simultaneously we know that distinct
reason cardiac output has to go and
supply the tissues and organs and blood
vessels on the arterial side they get
dilated because of that lead to an
improved effusion but that is the path
of physiological mechanism but it so
compared to present we saw pastors sense
happen or life open it there is no
evidence of Tolerance so based
oppressors they do developed our turns
the police oppressors presently use the
increased heart rate here it is our
trade then vascular resistance increases
here it decreases the increase in
cardiac output is because of increase
the heart rate here increase cardiac
output is because of venous return there
are beta receptors involved which can
lead to arrhythmias here there are no
beta is a fault
we have conclusively found that movie
Theresa no baby
though isomers are present in the beso
beso clusters particularly doggy time
and life of it know why so much
there is evidence of Luud extravasation
there is no evidence with X here so the
goals of resuscitation like restoring
cardiac function improving the end organ
perfusion reversing metabolic form to
fan out all the goals are achieved and
so this is basically a stave and a
highly effective first in class
resuscitate evasion and and basically a
lot of value additions are being added
to the field used suppressors of the
treatment of shark hammer Egyptian by
highly save 10 times safety highly
effective reduction in mortality
innovative first in class medicine and
society benefit unmet threatening
life-threatening conditions so and
reducing the adverse effect so there are
limitations at present is the subject
population although it is multicentric
but was done only in one country not a
global trial we are now embarking on a
global trial he met with cheapest FDA
and there are positive feedback which we
got and this tense it is trying
starlings law we are recommending the D
composite made not useful and then it is
right now limited to hypovolemic shock
but there are it could be we are doing
experiment in animal models of peptic
top he will be used or not now we
although I'm not presenting the data but
we have already done three trials of and
we got similar finding to what we got in
Phase two and that phase three trial was
done and 105 patients and that trial
data has been presented to us FDA and we
have also applied for marketing
permission in India so
the next few months we do expect that we
should be able to get some positive
responses from the regulatory agencies
so this is an example of in the end I
thank you and if any questions please do
not hesitate to email me order so this
is an example of how in our Catholic
institution at Mythbusters University
when I was working as the Dean of
research and professor there we
discovered this discovered this compound
and found out a new use of this compound
and then we university protected it
intellectually intellectual properties
and which was licensed to the company
which I did in 2010 and now it has come
to the stage where it is about to come
out in market and in the US and other
countries on a global basis we are M we
are likely to embark on a phase 3 trial
and so the whole idea is that from
academic institution your basic research
and discoveries or innovations can also
do some new guidance or new mechanism by
which happy these does be done
particularly in this case it is which is
a type reading situation significant
unmet medical need it will be
significant advancement once we once it
is lost and we have post-marketing
turbulence and we find so thank you very
much and the end of my presentation
Thank You professor in your for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder professor gallery will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via e now that's all for now
thank you for joining us
hope to see you again say goodbye